I was 8 and my
brother was about 10.
We really wanted to go
camping without any adults.
My parents agreed as
long as we trained.
We were living in
the Arctic, so it
was cold temperatures and
storms and blizzards and bears.
But we wanted them to succeed in
their little mini first outing.
We wanted to raise the kids,
giving them the confidence
to do impossible things.
You learn to do
things yourself
because we need
to be able to deal
with the worst case scenarios.
The reality is if it's
blowing 100 kilometers an hour
and it's a storm, we're out
in the middle of nowhere.
Nobody's coming out to get you.
My parents knew that as well.
There's no rescue operation
if something bad happens.
There's no Hollywood
grand finale.
We'll be frozen.
We'll be dead.
We'll be eaten by a polar bear.
Go.
So this ice behind us is
quite impressive to look at,
but it's not very
impressive when
we're traveling through it.
We weren't that far out
when I remember my brother
had this, like, shock.
What do you see from up there?
Mostly more ice.
We wanted to cross
the Boothia Strait.
Looking out at it, it seemed
like a really bad idea.
But we knew if we pushed
across, which was the quickest
way, there's the
risk that somebody
would fall through the water
and just disappear out there.
So we're going to camp the
night and see if it solidifies.
A detour would add
about 500 kilometers
to our total trip, which
would put us in jeopardy
of running out of snow and ice.
So we started the
day in good hopes
that we could get
to the other side.
See, that's a fox.
There's something out there.
Birds don't make
that [BLEEP] sound.
Which would be neat
to see an Arctic fox,
but at the same time, foxes
tend to follow polar bears.
Polar Bears are a huge risk
anywhere in the Arctic,
especially around
open water 'cause
that's where they hunt seals.
Our biggest fear was having a
polar bear encounter in camp.
We had a bear fence--
basically, a tripwire, which
would hopefully wake us up.
They're so quiet, they
can sneak up on anything.
[MUSIC PLAYING]